foreign
[Music]
all right
and put your hand where my wallet goes
and grows and put your hand where my
money
[Music]
call me
all right
[Music]
now put your mouth
thank you
babe babe I'm gonna do this do it these
are prescription really I forgot my
regular prescription right so I'm just
putting them on for now I'm not trying
to be too cool these are not
prescriptions but I tell people they're
prescription because I get embarrassed
from just wearing them to try to look
cool
but they are not prescription I thought
you passed that I thought you owned it I
did but then I can't say I'm a flawed
human I go back and forth okay and
speaking of back and forth I don't have
for the first time I don't have like a
hey babe I know we started just now
without singing We don't say that yeah I
don't have one at all well I have one
have you heard Joe derose's new album
what are you talking about Joe DeRosa
has a what do you mean his new music
album
just wait for it it's a joke this is the
Black Keys
you know is this the black case you
surprise me because I didn't think you
would know the Black Keys but then even
if you did I didn't think yeah it does
sound like the bike if it's black I love
it yeah
who is this
Joseph DeRosa taste buds Fame
and who is it for real
it's Joey roses himself what do you mean
this is this is Joe derose's actual
voice salsa Wind Falls back they
released announcement this is salsa
windfall yeah the name of his band is
salsa windfall I I did he ever explain
that wait wait hold on a second stop
this that literally this sounds like a
that sounds like a burrito place in
Orlando yeah yeah it sounds like it
sounds like it sounds like an
all-you-can-eat buffet burritos yeah
there's a windfall of South I'm going to
Orlando I can get I go to the salsa
windfall with Mike family yeah what is
it it's it's a bit like it's like the
Olive Garden's never-ending pasta bowl
yes it's like you go to a place and it's
just a salsa until you can't take salsa
no more who would want a windfall of
salsa I don't know but is it he's got us
talking he that's a good point Salsa
Salsa or salsa I'm saying Salsa Salsa
but it's probably a salsa is the dance
salsa so I think salsa is both that's a
good point is there a difference between
Salsa the dance and salsa the food I
think the spelling is identical but the
names are different but they feel like
yeah from a white woman Saul
Saul salsa like David tell calls me Saul
Saul
wait so wait pimp hold on wait a second
but that really is that it's wait it's
also windfall just Joe DeRosa are there
other people involved in the band I I
think there's one other from what I
gathered and I did see I just retweeted
for him that he he said a new album's
dropping and this is it it's out it's up
well this is the single that we're
filming a music video for but you're
filming the music video for this song
yes what is the name of the song
starring the great Jeffrey Gurion oh I
love Jeffrey Guardian
laughs
Jeffrey green how's he doing he's alive
yeah
[Laughter]
wait a second it looks like he literally
literally literally like a smoke you see
smoke and glowing just a click thick
cloud of smoke and some glowing and like
those stairs from the Flying Saucer come
down and then he just steps out from a
flying saucer he looks like an alien
Jeffrey he looks like someone from the
70s I think he got I think he got
possessed by an alien in the 70s he did
I think Jeffrey gorion he looks like
he's old and young at the same time he I
don't he's he is I love him
he's he he's a beloved New York presence
in the comedy scene
he is very unique would you say he's a
one of a one he's very unique if you
don't have a picture or if you're in
comedy and you don't have a picture with
Jeffrey guring and you've never been
interviewed by Jeffrey gurin then you're
not really a New York comedy because he
is the he gets to everybody yeah we love
him Jeffrey he looks like Elton John uh
had sex with uh Frankie Valli yes
do you ever see look at a young Jeffrey
girl in with this must establish in the
glasses you see all the way to the right
with Phil Hartman oh my god there it is
wow and he's a dentist on his off time
Jeffrey going to stop it stop it no he's
not he's a fully licensed we've known
the guy he's he's fully licensed he's a
fully licensed dentist yep yep on his
off time yep he's a fully like only did
I ever hear him see dude talk about or
consume his time with is common he might
not be a practicing dentist but then
when you go in his house there's
balloons everywhere right yeah he's
obsessed with balloons if you walk into
his an apartment he did a documentary on
it everywhere you go there's balloon
wait this has nothing to do with the
Dentistry well yeah that's just obsessed
with balloons teeth and comedy
you've been in this house
you look blind
uh no we've seen the documentary he has
a documentary did he make it on himself
right we watched this documentary yeah I
forget who made it you need to tell me
that you walk in his house and it looks
like basically the ceiling of the prom
yes he's got below and every and you'll
open up drawers and there's balloons
that like there's balloons everywhere
yes
there's something just when you thought
you kind of like
you don't know just when you thought you
might know somebody you don't he also
had a heart attack in the street so no
one would help him right and during
covid yeah right yeah yeah nobody would
help him and you see big J do his
impression of Jeffrey Gurion no
um you're you okay and I and I'm Jeffrey
Gurion and just start talking about
something hey Jeff
um I
did you did you know that you have a
look it's a pan and just starts looking
at you
how come you haven't had big J on this
show
I don't know is this salsa windfall
again yeah just throwing some salsa
windfall in there this sounds like the
like the start screen to an 8-bit game
on Nintendo this sounds like it should
be in stranger things yeah the title of
this track is genius is the worst wait
can you pause this because this is
just so you know I'm overwhelmed by this
information and the just what I've heard
I've already feel a wave of something
come with me and I'm overwhelmed by it
yeah my hands are going numb
we are I see Joe often we see on the
record I see him when I don't record he
goes with me on the road
there is three to five minute voice
memos yeah so I
I constant communication with JoJo same
same never did I hear one second that he
was in a studio or in his home with this
other person creating music
18 for a new album he's never mentioned
it I never heard him go I can't tonight
I'm doing I'm just I'm writing some
music I can't tonight we're recording
music nope I I mean never once and I'm
with him 24 7 nearly 19 tracks 19. when
did he do this when did he produce yeah
who produced it oh is it pinch records I
think pinch recording pinch records so
he didn't produce it
even let's not muddy his credits I don't
know who who's crazy
right lyrics so does he get the music
and write lyrics or is he getting
someone giving music and then he writes
the little pimp is you're a music
Aficionado in your professional opinion
is he writing these lyrics doing these
beats what what's he doing I think you
can hear the pain in the tortured
artists Behind These lyrics he is yes oh
this isn't entertainment
does this have a comedic thing to it or
is it no no no purely real art okay what
category would you say it falls under as
far as music uh a tour pop wait a second
wait a second wait a second wait a
second what do you mean just uh is it
like pie I think you need to listen to
some of this album I can't I can't put
him in a box am I am I am I gonna have
salsa windfall close my show at Radio
City
here's what we're gonna do here's what
we're gonna do for Radio City or theater
and MSG we're gonna have Joe deroza the
comic open the show we're gonna have Joe
derose's sandwich shop K to the show and
then Joe the Rose's music room close the
show wow yes three businesses and he's
getting work on all of them in one shot
the last three businesses and almost
needs a roommate
listen you can tell you a joke make a
sandwich and sing this song though
that's it let me tell you something
about Joe Duro can we play because I got
to be honest with you I'm being and this
is completely 100 true I the first 10
seconds of of the song that pimp was
playing I like like if that was on the
radio I would stop and be like huh it is
not bad music by any stretch of the
imagination no I I have no idea what it
is and I'm hoping I love it and I'm yeah
I I'm not saying anything about it I
haven't heard it I just don't know when
he made this I don't know what he made
you guys want to choose a track look at
the titles but what is APTA what's out
that people can listen to well hopefully
by the time we drop this what's the
first single yeah what's the it is money
where my mouth money on my mouth let's
listen to my mouth mouth on my money
salsa unknown artist so and you're the
listener can hear this along with us yes
okay listen
oh
I like this so far so good
but is he playing his instrument was he
making this
I've never met this man who is he
he's a generational Talent
cool
dude
now put your mouth
put your mouth
man
my money shines
chicken bones Chicken Chicken Bone
Daddy's Home
downtown
[Music]
[Applause]
what does that even mean now put your
mouth
wow and I like this one fire I love that
song He's got an effect on his voice is
he the only one singing who's the other
guy what does the other guy where you
hear other vocals
no nothing's officially published yet he
will be in and all right let's let's do
first of all I like that song I like
that song Would You categorize it as
like well it does sound like The Black
Keys it feels like LMFAO combined with
the Black Keys yeah it was like a little
bit of like it was like
like pop dance rock yeah like something
pop yeah Dive Bar disco you want to try
uh I like to be listening to Jesus is
the worst yeah I think you just coined
something you coined what the Roses yes
Dive Bar disco tell him that see oh did
you did you uh do Geniuses the worst yet
pimp uh that you you started that one
you remember at the beginning so let's
do so what about Frozen next that's a
that's a thumbs up on that track I
thumbs up on mouth where my money is
mouth on my
I'm literally gonna be humming it I'm
gonna sing
clever
what are you guys feeling next
um you want to try Frozen nectar
let's just give it a shot yeah
you should do on taste buds Frozen
nectar versus deep dish
14 verse tracks
oh life could be much worse when the sun
don't shine and the rain come down all
day yo it's a blessing
oh life could be much worse why is he
singing this one with a British accent
acapella
oh this is the whole track well okay
okay so let's talk about this track all
right so let's this track hits different
than the numbers let's let this is
different it's it's
a British accent I don't hate it but I
do like mouth on my money is more fun
yes but like you said this isn't it
sounded like uh like almost like he was
singing acapella to a a sitcom theme
song that exists that's not acapella
it's the best in life could be my chores
it just sounds like you like you know I
don't hate it I do feel like the whole
album is a film and that's a
transitional beat right okay all right
so why don't we see them what's next
mission statement let's see what Frozen
is that cool Frozen nectar though I
don't know okay right after Frozen
nectares number seven yeah let's see
what it leads into let's see yeah
what is this instrument is this like
some kind of scent sin
what a synth
synth gender
[Music]
I know
just in your own hands
[Music]
that also sounded like it's the
beginning of a song is about to drop so
okay so Frozen nectar leads into mission
statement which then leads into Mouse on
my money right so then you get the
Banger mouth of my money so Joe let me
ask you because you I don't so Joe I
didn't realize Joe had an interest I had
no idea this type of sound I had no idea
and I would like to say it does have an
Eclectic music taste he's into punkies I
mean look at that kind of pants he did
argue against weed on taste buds and
that felt very weed inspired well that's
why that leads me to want to sample this
next track it's also windfall track
number 17 you buggin
I love that that sounds I liked it you
bug it is interesting
[Music]
here we go wait this all feels like it's
keyboard
some kind of keyboard or that's probably
what he had in his apartment
it's what he had in his apartment
[Music]
I like a little laugh
you bugging
coming up with these beats right because
how else could you write the songs to
them like you have to write the lyrics
to the beat I think you I think anyone
any process works but I mean like he
doesn't know how to make this music does
he he might we don't know we don't even
know he made music we didn't know he
made an album how do we know what JoJo
Rose even does I have no idea what JoJo
Rosa does anymore me neither I don't
know if I'm gonna give him a moment is
he making a sandwich or a song I thought
like if he was to get married like I
would probably be like in his in his
wedding party and I don't even know he
made an album yeah that's that's like
isn't it it's almost like makes me feel
like a little violated what are you
doing amazing if he got married I mean
we're like all in the wedding party
that's amazing amazing um I would love
it I would like okay if you're dumb
enough ladies
this one's called Baby nasty oh baby
nasty okay
[Music]
this feels a little like Indie pop yeah
indie rock pop I don't hate any of these
I like mouth of my money is the Banger
so far
[Music]
the baby Nasty Baby nasty by the way my
daughter the other day had a full
shit-filled piss-filled diaper took it
off and threw it at Jasmine took it off
Airborne threw that Jasmine it was wild
yeah she just get the baby's getting to
that phase that when they're too they
take the diaper off
this is very weird for a single 45 year
old man to be seen
let me cry he wrote At The Cellar doro's
just not coming to my house anymore now
he wrote it staring at the school across
the funerals
Honestly though this is good music it's
like this now this feels retro if your
poolside chilling this summer why not
throw on salsa windfall I I'm not
kidding it's easy listen it sounds like
80s like this sounds like 80s like New
Wave like Post Punk stuff yeah which it
is yeah I feel like this is very mod
like this would play over like an 80s
movie montage yeah I feel like it's
gonna be all over Tick Tock it's great
oh hell yeah
did you ever call them and go what are
you doing he's like I just gotta I just
gotta write some music so not as a
matter of fact every time I call Joe he
picks up on the first ring so
so when is he making this music
he's like hello
yeah not doing anything I I he must make
this in the middle of the night for real
he must
go
he puts a mouth on his money how's the
little baby crawled to him what you want
to uh quick back to school tip yes you
can cross everything off your list
before the big day with dodash Wow stock
up on supplies and lunchtime snacks all
in one place I'm looking for a gold star
get it all back to back school hack the
first day back is almost here and so are
the long list of Essentials your kids
need for class with doordash you can
find everything they need all in one
place for an A plus year baby you're
talking about convenience with
delivering an hour okay all your
favorite retail grocery convenience
stores are on that app you can fill the
kids backpacks and bellies and Pantry
for this back to school season be
prepared before the big day arrives shop
doordash to get everything you need for
the back to school season delivered
right to your door order now for a
stress-free back-to-school shopping use
promo code
babe2023 to get 50 off up to a ten
dollar value when you spend 15 or more
at convenience grocery or retail stores
on doordash that's fifty percent off up
to a ten dollar value when you spend 15
or more promo code babe 2023. don't
forget yes that's babe 2023 for 50 off
your next order terms apply
babe I got a brand new hour of stand-up
material I'm filming a special for it in
December so come see it live before then
we got Atlantic City New Jersey the
borgato August 18th 19th September 5th
and 6th Irvine California September 8th
Portland September 9th Seattle and then
of course September 22nd and 23rd we
have Radio City Music Hall in New York
City and the theater at MSG
um and then September 30th is Las Vegas
Nevada and then all my October November
December dates are chrisdcomedy.com get
tikiwickies
all right guys big news I've mentioned
it before but December early December
I'm filming my special in Chicago uh and
I will not say where it's going to be at
but the tour for that special is ramping
up right now starting in August and
going through to November uh you can get
tickets at savocanocarity.com and these
are some of the tickets uh some of the
places I'm going now if this is this is
coming out on the 13th uh with hey babe
right so today is July 13th the pre-sale
is going on right this second uh on sale
will happen uh tomorrow Friday July 14th
so today is the day if you want to beat
everybody out for those tickets the
pre-sale is happening at savocano
comedy.com and use the code no pressure
p-r-e-s-h I'm coming through Bowling
Green Cincinnati Toledo Wilkes bar
Wilmington Macon Georgia Savannah Athens
Georgia Peoria Rockford Cedar Rapids
Springfield Illinois Duluth Rochester
Davenport and Elkhart in uh Elkhart
Indiana
um that is all uh in prep for the
special so go online right now and grab
those if it's not July 13th into hearing
this they're on sale so just get them
also
January is the Impractical Jokers cruise
with Eric Andre it's our fifth one and
we did it five times because it is so
goddamn fun so uh you get tickets there
get shipfaced.com and then of course if
you want to catch the Jokers on the last
weekend of this leg of the tour we won't
be returning it until 24. you can go to
impracticaljokerslive.com July 27th
through the 29th we're going to be doing
um St Louis Indianapolis and Nashville
at the Grand Ole Opry I hope to see you
guys on the road uh and I and I cannot
wait to do special so Chicago tell a
friend it's going to be great I'll tell
you what's it going to be better than
this do you know what's gonna be better
than this what do you know because I'll
tell you it's gonna blow the balls off
this which one
no what's better than this experience
right now oh you know what it is going
to watch it live live
watch it live and we're gonna do maybe
we do a podcast class trip to go watch
it live where do we sell that out
we pack out like Arlene's grocery or
something like that and we go watch this
live why don't we do it even bigger why
don't we do salsa why don't we do the
first hey babe live which is also
windfall at The Gramercy theater why
don't we do that should we do that a hey
babe live at the grammar see where you
can same thing in the taste but you can
stream in and the same thing and then
it's a salsa windfall concert live
performance live performance
wait does he have a guy another bandmate
or whatever
he does who is this guy I thought I knew
all those friends I bet you could do it
because this probably is going to play
to a track I don't think he's playing
this stuff live yeah he's almost not
like on the keys I think it's like more
like a rap show yeah God did he think of
it did he form this band in College Town
Pennsylvania where he's from
Collegeville this is well you know about
the band the band's old no I don't know
about the band the band is he
to buy music equipment and then became a
comedian you didn't know that behind me
well I think Joe did hip hop and stuff
because his name was uh what's his name
no no he's like track 17. I think his
name was example yes is that it ex right
exact example yeah wow you didn't know
he he had a legitimate that he performed
in a hip-hop group the only thing I knew
about Joe with music is one day we were
doing in Vegas we were doing uh Josh
Adam Meyer's show the um goddamn comedy
goddamn Comedy Jam great show John China
Myers and I did it I sang a little
Whitney Houston and then DeRosa went on
after me before me I can't imagine I
can't uh remember an absolutely
annihilated like look like a rock star
foot up on the speaker
oh this guy's done this before like he's
played music but I didn't think he was a
rapper named example yeah he is you know
I'm you know I'm doing the goddamn
Comedy Jam
um Friday I don't I don't know when this
is coming out but I'm going to
Pittsburgh for a chart even for Mario
lemieu would burn right and if you want
to comment do you want to know what song
I chose I narrowed it down to two Okay
let me well I picked the one let me try
to guess what genre yes it's 80s New
Wave 80s New Wave I think you're playing
uh Wham
no but that's wonderful okay okay I
think you're playing Elton John no
circle of life no that's definitely not
New Wave 80s but what's new wave 80s
give me an example of New Wave 80s
that's not what you picked okay uh it's
like
um
New Order
um it's like uh uh uh uh
um it's like your Joy Division Depeche
Mode oh okay okay so somebody like that
okay so then it's um so then um so then
what you are new new wave 80s I think
then what you're doing is
um
uh uh
take a wishful thinking you know a lot
no that's not even that's like 80
[Music]
s straight regular that's from the
Pretty Woman soundtrack yeah I love that
song I love that as a matter of fact
when I was when I think I was like one
of my first breakups and stuff I would I
would play that song and like feel it
because isn't the first I don't need to
stare at your feet yeah just uh to cause
you come into the bone and I did not
tears in my eyes
I did uh what is this
just a little background music for you
guys
this feels like this new way you know
this music now sounds like what Buffalo
Bill tucks his dick and balls back to in
science of the Lambs that's what this
song is
that when you're applying lipstick yeah
put some lotion in the basket which me
I'd be listening to salsa windfall that
should be the music video Jeffrey Gurion
tuck back
just blind lipstick wait a second it
would be a Smash Smash Hit
50 songs new if you know like it's also
like it's stuffed like that like was
poppy like uh Take On Me Take On Me
[Laughter]
in the beginning like you died
um it's you I I'm doing Erasure Erasure
yes a little respect a little respect
how do you do I try to discover
one second
let me hear that
I'm gonna tell you for real favorite
I hear you hear you call yes
oh baby
yes this this okay that I've heard I
thought that was a Bop
it is it is but I just haven't heard it
I didn't realize it it's got something
to do with this song okay I love you but
that that song that song was the song
wait before we move on I just want to
say quickly that salsa windfall we've
listened to a bit of the album yeah the
single is out the album's out go to
salsa windfall on Spotify go get it Joe
deroza's band that we did not know even
existed yes we did not know even existed
and we truly genuinely I want to say it
out loud so it actually happens are
going to do a show in New York City the
live our first live hey babe that we
will stream just like the taste buds and
if we can get salsa windfall to commit
they will be the musical act that will
be their first live show our hey babe
with special guests and special stuff
just like they did with taste buds but
then salsa windfall being the Big Time
guest I love I love it I love it I love
it do you do you definitely want to do
this
live and I think we go live if Joe
DeRosa was gonna make me trying to
stream live I mean live audience too you
live audience plus stream live oh why
don't we also film like a music video
because if we get everybody to go Rush
the stage and jump around yes you can
get those angles they're like it almost
looks like he's in concert I love that
so we want it for the next single
because we already got the video but I
say we do a live show you know we'll do
like a thousand seed or a lot we'll make
it big live show plus live stream I
think we do that right pimp it cannot
easily be done in these venues yeah we
do that same way as taste buds because
my thing is is if JoJo Rosa was gonna
make me dress up as an Eminem with high
heels and not pay me one dollar to do
that live taste buds then he's getting
on my life hey babe and he's gonna
repay me by playing salsa with
all that and that goddamn show and maybe
a fun outfit yes and a fun outfit okay
yes and yeah I should make him go out in
the Eminem costume with the high
heels and play sauce away one thing he
has he has a punishment going from the
loss of season two yeah okay so that
could be it oh he could do salsa
windfall in the Eminem outfit okay okay
he has to agree to it no maybe not the
heels because I want him to jam out but
because he really is flashed but yeah
but do we like that idea of the live hey
babe I do I just had to wrap my head
around what yeah I do why not because I
think it would you know if it's local we
would think it's easy
I will say when we did the live hey
babes in the train tracks in the Dust
Bowl shout out sold y'all amazing I mean
he really knows how to he has a list and
they all came out we sold so many
tickets to that but it was like 100
degrees outside we're not doing that
Outdoors yeah but I do remember like
it's it's tough right because we we end
up playing you have to it's a live
performance you end up playing to the
crowd a little right because they're
there they're there to play them and
then so then they kind of can deviate
from like a conversation we normally
have without them but I think we got
through it and we we had the crowd come
up we had a couple of bits planned and
again it was 100 degrees it was Outdoors
we were working against the elements
live indoors in a theater I think we
have a few bits planned you're the king
with Team practical jokers of knowing
how to do that live type of show
obviously wouldn't be as intricate as
that but we would do it I think what it
is is that we do we have to do just a
bunch of bits we'll have some free talk
we can think of we could really do we
could think of seven to ten of them yeah
yeah you know um and I think we do it
and maybe we put this on till we do this
for the fall because I think that it's
it's a genuinely good idea and I want to
see and we we do it we do our part for
40 45 minutes and then salsa windfall
takes us home yeah I like that a lot
it's also windfall when you know you
have a closed Banger closer it's also
windfall you really don't have to do
much else I know do you think that it
would play they play the one song I
think they play a few of their songs
through their songs I think they play a
few of their songs salsa winfall play
some few of the songs well are they
playing like they are interlude yes you
know what I mean yes or does it like or
do they just close it out
I think they close it think about it
yeah we think about it but I think they
close it out
I think we drop a disco ball down let
everybody on stage 100 it's just just a
party right 100 of insurance
we'll figure it out we'll figure it all
heard him say it
we'll figure it all out
um so uh moving on then we want to get
speaking of the live when we did the
live Alex Edelman studying apples yes he
does look like Alexander and altona's
got a great one-man show out now that
I've heard it's amazing uh I've seen it
I saw it I saw it off off when it first
came out I loved it I loved it yeah um
now it's on action now for real Broadway
it's I didn't I found this out two days
ago I got a text to that it's actually
on actual Broadway I don't think it's
even off-broad no no it's it's a For
Real Broadway show I he's got a play
Bill two weeks ago I went to go I went
to Radio City to go see Ricky Gervais
yeah I want to talk to Ricky Gervais and
it was amazing Ricky Gervais is awesome
who connected you there was it was it
Burke so it's interesting right this is
what it is did he know you or did you
have to get introduced and then did you
oh did you stay in the shadows until he
spoke to you or was it like you were
sitting with him in this we never spoke
I was told by you know my agents and the
people that set it up you will get one
minute with Ricky like he's preparing
for Radio City just say hi don't ask for
a picture which I never would just say
hi to him and go I was like great he's
like my favorite comic of all time I've
always looked up to his work so I'm like
let me just meet him real quick and go
down I want and his his uh his guy his
man his own personal manager was the
nicest guy ever was like Hey I'm gonna
take you and see him you know I don't
know like probably just in and out but
he was like the coolest guy I go in
there as soon as I go in I I see I walk
in I see his opener Sean McLaughlin who
was hilarious and then Ricky and as soon
as I said oh hey Ricky I'm Chris
estefano um I I was told that it was
okay to just come say hi to he goes
absolutely mate take a seat and then he
sat and then I sat down there with him
for like 45 minutes and just talked to
Ricky and his opener but then 10 minutes
into that conversation who comes walking
in Alex Edelman Alex animal comes
walking in with uh Jewish Bagels that he
brought to Ricky Gervais I was like on
Brands I was like I didn't bring social
that's what I said why did I not come
with a pizza and and so and then
they were they go way back Alex and
Ricky I think Alex used to open up frame
whatever but they were talking about the
show and then Ricky was even saying to
Alex like you know you have a Broadway
show he's like it's crazy like it's
crazy like but Alex Edelman said he was
like I'm doing stand-up like it is my
hour of stand-up material on Broadway so
it's like a different experience and I I
was leaving Radio City about two hours
after that when Ricky let out I'm
walking across the street I see Michael
Rapaport I'm like oh hey what's up man
he goes what's up he goes dude I just
came from Alex edelman's show it's
amazing you got to go see edelman's show
so I want to go see it I haven't seen I
I don't I didn't even think I saw the
off off Broadway one but I want to like
go see the Broadway show so go see it
because all I've heard is it's amazing
yeah yeah I'll check it out with you I
want to do a one-man show why don't we
do more one-man shows you and I why
don't we do a one-man show but it's the
two of us but we call it the one-man
show yeah no we call it a one-man show
one-man show why don't you think you do
one-man shows and what's the difference
in your opinion between a one-man show
and an hour of stand-up sure I think
that you're looking at something as one
whole piece of work I think you're
looking at something that has a
beginning middle and end that has a
purpose that is basically you're leaving
with information you didn't have before
there's a commentary involved maybe or
there's just something real this really
like but we could do that in stand up I
could teach you a few state capitals
throughout the hour yeah yeah it's I
guess it's maybe less setup punch set a
punch and more like right you know more
I mean we know it I mean you know yeah
but I do but like can you take you have
to cry you know yeah I know
I think in a one-man show maybe there's
also moments of levity what would be fun
is to be at a comedy club like this is
my stand-up hour but I do the one man I
start crying I got the spotlight on I
have props I went to a comedy club and a
one-man show I I literally I'm at stand
up live in Phoenix which I will be there
in uh I believe December
um and I do the one-man show but I don't
tell the crowd it comes out I'm sitting
used the show starts the lights go low
light spot I'm sitting in a chair facing
the wall that's nothing usually there's
like minimal but some props there's some
lighting cues you know like you you I
sometimes there's an act out like but in
the space not as a person like you know
what I mean like did you see the new
season of I think you should leave yet
oh you haven't seen it yet is it is it
as good as one until Christopher is it
as good as one what did she say get rid
of it
um I want to do a whole album of all my
old bits by the way because Comedy
Central and everyone and they've owned
them for years they've made enough money
on them I'm gonna now do a Taylor like
shifted like Jerry Steinfeld yeah Taylor
Swift read released
it's called something so Jerry did I'm
telling you for the last time it was all
somebody owned them before
uh see like that's the thing it's like
that you they give you like these they
give you these deals early in your
careers and you think you're making some
money you're not making they're making
all the money so it's not making any
dick so go yeah did you ever get did you
ever go in a elevator and I'm gonna get
to the bottom he goes
Lobby yeah
Lobby yes yeah
um so yeah so you do that and then I
think that there has to be moments where
you maybe like fake oh so I think you
should leave oh so good is he does you
like it it's it's it's it's nothing
nothing's better than the second season
it's not as good as a second in my
opinion that being said it's okay it's
great it's great it's just that the
second season
it just was a sweet spot for me right
now when he the first sketch of the
second season when he with the hot
eating the hot dog and then the second
sketch the coffin flop is those are
amazing yeah and then he's got the uh
it's too much on me
the common Lagoon and then you got the
one leads right into big fat low to come
then yeah he's like yeah yeah yeah and
you can't curse so so it's a third
season so that's different so this this
great great ones there's a little more
in this one that I was lukewarm on
usually I like season two there's almost
no misses to me there's like a handful
not even but there is really fun is it
one of them he's a there's a guy that
does a one-man show on Broadway and he's
doing the commercial for and he's like
come see me and it's like you know
whatever his name is he goes whatever
like you know
Ernie Johnson does 75 scenes so with no
words and like he does a little
vignettes and then he go and he has like
a like a little like Fedora on like a
he's like almost like a mime guy and he
pushes the door he goes and I never talk
right and then the whole the whole thing
is if he talks he's got to pay the
audience so it catches on and people
start going and screaming at him to make
him talk he can't resist talking dude
it's so funny that one you're like dying
laughing it's so funny yeah that was a
classic and I never talk yeah it's
really good you got to watch it I gotta
watch it I think you should leave I
think that like the hour I'm about to do
is a lot of Storytelling okay yeah it's
like storytelling bit storytelling
because I don't want to just do all
stories but like it is and I wonder if
there is connective tissue between them
all I'm trying to figure out what's in
like name the special and what to put in
and what order and everything like that
now so I kind of like looking at it like
that in a way right now right I think I
might there's a I might I notice a
through line in a lot of my stories was
that I'm scared right of things I'm
sorry and everything you know scare
itself yeah like I was just thinking of
like maybe like I'm terrified or
something like okay terrified does that
look yeah terrified
pterodactyl I got a whole list I have an
oh no to like 30 names for the special
depending well I'm running by you I
think for this health and safety of my
children of any children that will ever
be born we should make them go Amish
because Amish children new study finds
zero cell zero Amish children diagnosed
with cancer diabetes or Autism zero zero
not not a one
not a one now I don't know if that's
because if they find out they're born
with it they turn them into butter
get those because they're molasses
they're literally Malad but have an
average of seven kids wait but why do
you think that is because they don't
consume um um uh uh maybe processed
foods and stuff yeah right
um yeah and they they reject all modern
medicine and pharmaceutical drugs uh
wait can you go what do they what are
they free of
autism and cancer is zero not a one and
they have seven kids per family let me
ask you a question that means then that
every Amish kid alive went into testing
or maybe the the the the the government
the CDC went around sort of rounding
them up they started how many Amish are
they take a guess first of all the Amish
only in Amish Country and that's it I
think they're in I think they're ever
like is there an Amish person in
Schenectady I think they're in Lancaster
Pennsylvania I think they're also in
Ohio I think the the Disney World of the
Amish is Lancaster Pi I think that's the
but there's not really Satellite City
that's the capital I think you have a
few in Ohio 360
000. I didn't realize it was that many
we should be the first podcast who
specifics we should be trying to get the
Amish can we get an Amazon will they
come on I've been trying to make contact
for a few weeks now but it's hard
because they have no technology
is Amish there oh 360 30 States all Ohio
Indiana Pennsylvania
so they really yeah because you can't
really go south with them in Florida I
thought Pennsylvania was the place that
is no it is Pennsylvania because the
Pennsylvania Dutch the Amish are the
German Dutch yeah oh no they're Dutch I
know I think they speak German the
Pennsylvania I think that I think that
the Amish speak German really I'm almost
positive why do you think they keep why
okay look look look look right so they
reject what is their what is their
mission statement they they re they they
want is it that they want to live pure
they want to reject like technology why
yes and I think that if you take a
picture of an Amish they think it steals
your soul we stand for the verbally
inspired word of God okay the Trinity
the deity of Christ his blood atonement
salvation by faith separation from the
world
Soul winning and pre-millennial return
of Christ wow that's heavy it's a lot of
stuff that's a lot of things Yeah by
following the four principal values of
faith I could my family community and
living a simple amount of life okay
that's not like that I like that
actually a lot the Amish live out their
own religious
Meek life in their own spiritual way
right now
there's a modified Amish right the
Mennonites
and then watches The Tonight Show the
Mennonites they drive minivans and they
have technology they look and act like
Amish they are Amish on the external
every step of the way but the Mennonites
will use technology so the purists have
a problem with the Mennonites yes
there's beef oh there's beef there's so
there's civil beef because they're not
pure and then the rum Springer is when
they let the Amish
when the rumps when they leave for rum
Springer the kids they give the kids an
opportunity to see what life outside the
Amish Clan is like and 95 of the kids
come back from Springer I got news for
you it's probably better it's probably
because that's why they say like even
sometimes communism they say it's like
when you don't have any when you don't
have anything to kind of strive for you
sometimes you have like an easier life
because you're like I don't have to now
try to reach for the stars it ain't
possible I have a question
that was my question
I just wanted to know can anyone become
Amish but you have to come from a
descendant of the Dutch and be in the in
literally in blood the bloodline okay so
let's talk about the steps to becoming
Amish and by the way if you know an
Amish person or if you're an Amish
person and you're listening and we know
that you are we'd love for you to come
to our life hey babe person named Amish
once you know a person named I knew one
like a long time ago I know a person
named Amish well he said his name no his
name was Sheamus hey Miss Sheamus yeah
all right okay here we go confession of
Faith Amish people's Divine faith in God
is what drives all other decisions their
Traditions customs and Norms have all
sprung from the truth baptism you gotta
see this whatever we say it doesn't
matter you gotta baptism yeah um you got
it I know it's like David tells got a
good joke from like uh
um skanks For The Memories he goes let's
talk let's make fun of the Amish thing
or we can make fun of the Amish they're
not even listening or something like
something funny nice
35 years later yes
um you'll have to become baptized into
the Amish life
um they can't even get married with wait
this is this is one of the tower coins
to become Amish even Amish born people
must undergo baptism before they can
play a role in the community they can't
even get married before doing so as both
parties must be baptized as Amish to get
married you have to okay the Amish abide
by the law set out in the law book
called The ordung or the ordnung
ornament this contains guidelines for
life on all types of topics and when you
join the Amish you'll be expected to
follow these rules too it's a little bit
like being in the cartel you can't get
out once you're in it is a little bit
like being in like it feels a little
cultish not in a bad way not a bad no
like they follow rules and stuff now not
only I think they're gonna figure it out
I think they got to figure out now I
love the Simplicity and the disconnect
and the state the sense of community and
family I don't know if I could deal with
like like following like the world like
the word the law of God and what are the
bathing rules too can they can they
shower can they could do they have
running water do they have to bathe in a
while do they have to use like shea
butter to clean themselves can they get
like a salon selective because I'm
almost positive that the Amish that we
see today look identical and act
identical to the Amish that lived 400
years ago I used to use a beard bomb
called honest Amish I believe it was
called right and it was excellent and uh
I think I guess they made it right
that's one of those you're like if
you're Amish can you get filthy rich
I know that Amish people who pays them
they do school work like they do one
Schoolhouse they go old school with
school that's how School obviously wait
a minute wait a minute wait a minute
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait if they have their
own jobs like they all have their own
jobs within the they're a
self-sustaining Community correct am I
incorrect like an Amish guy doesn't work
at Blockbuster right I don't think so
then
what currency do they deal in
like are they are they rooted no look
here we go Amish have checking accounts
and some even use credit cards they use
dollars when buying things from one
another and from non-amish sources alike
so they might even still be bartering
they might do bartering damage don't do
a lot of old-fashioned bartering
contrary to someone to what some might
think the Amish don't do a lot of
old-fashioned bartering and training
they use dollars when buying things and
they have checking accounts and even
some use credit cards Amisha Dalton
married couples typically have checking
accounts and this form of payment is
very common okay okay so I mean you have
to I mean you have to adapt someone to
society so I think they also buy things
from non-amer sources like grocery
stores convenience Superstores like
Walmart and Costco that'd be funny to
see an Amish person in Costco just
getting tons of what yeah what are you
getting hey what do you need as an Amish
person I don't know they're allowed to
like vacation sometimes I remember I was
in a hot tub with an Amish family in
Florida were they in full were they in
their clothes some of the clothes they
were yeah I was being facetious were you
saying somebody got in fully with the
hat on suspenders
they go down to their Bare Bones layers
but they have the suspenders on so they
were nice they
nice
I went to we used to we used to go to
the Amish Country for clash trips always
yeah like it's like 100 uh uh Kitchen
Kettle all that stuff my uncle took a
picture one sec I want to read that yeah
okay my uncle took a picture of an Amish
person on his um with his wife I might
they might even win on their honeymoon
to the Lancaster which is weird but this
happened years ago the story host was
retold to me he took a picture of an
Amish guy the Amish guy flanked I swear
to God flagged him down on a horse and
buggy stopped him asked for the camera
said please give me that camera because
because you've taken a picture of me and
it stole my soul so I need you to get
because it was at a point where you had
to the film took the film took that
piece of film out somehow or maybe got
rid of all the film and then said to my
uncle I am so sorry for having to do
this please accept this shoe fly pie
that my wife made as payment and gave my
uncle a free shoe fly pie which he said
was amazing shoe fly pie sounds like a
track in the new salsa wouldn't fall out
yeah shoe fly pie recipe you got a half
a cup of flour okay uh you're gonna go
down a little bit that looks delicious
why is it flour brown sugar water spices
and sometimes an egg top of the crumb
mixture served in a flaky pie crust
shoo-fly pie it's similar to coffee cake
but with a goose molasses bottom let me
tell you something around
yeah it's fun yeah but it's not
appetized yeah I don't I don't I don't
like that at all shoe fly pie by the way
I love I love I think pie uh coffee cake
is my favorite type of cake I can't do
coffee cake hey you know what I did you
know what that was
um I can't do coffee cake
babe
Ron's tail babe why did he say that
coffee cake throw them in the throw them
in the bag all right coffee cake Sonny
had five fingers but he only used three
two coffee cake because I can't do
coffee cake yeah yeah I know that whole
thing
um
um wait there was something else about
you wanted to read why was the loans in
borrowing because I'm fascinated with
how they integrate into our society and
where that line is when buying a home or
starting a business I thought they built
their own homes or starting a business
how much people will make use of several
resources of capital traditional bank
loans are a common way that Amish people
finance and home purchase how do they
back it up though how are they granted a
loan if they're not working in like you
you never an Amish is this not
mind-blowing to you an Amish person only
works within the jobs of the Amish
community and you will never see an
Amish person like an office up at like
Google right so then so then how okay
who's paying them and how do they show
up get this loan let me ask you this why
don't you do this we can either do this
I got I got I got the next page Amish
run the lending they run the lending
firm and then it says in some
communities like Lancaster CA the price
of land has become prohibitive and young
aspiring Farmers may be forced to move
to areas where land is cheaper you might
we might be living in the world where
the Amish get priced out and they may
have to open up a farm right here on
Staten Island they're gonna they're
gonna they're gonna uh yes they're going
to come in and what's that called when
you come in the neighborhood
justification yeah they're gonna gentle
they're going to formificate it well let
me ask you this yeah full you have to
answer this question fight to the fair
fight to the death okay in a fair if
they're shooting the fair one if they're
shooting the fair one who do you got
your money on the Amish or Hasidic Jews
who do you got in one of physical this
fight let's do we'll do fist fight then
we'll do spelling bee and then we'll do
math off who do you got and I actually
wish people are gonna literally
literally annihilate in math uh
annihilate yeah annihilate yeah I mean I
feel like they're still like they're
still using Abacus yeah but and Jewish
people around the world but that's the
thing the Amish might know like angles
and stuff where the sun is like they
might don't sleep on Amish people's math
okay fist fighting Amish they work with
their hands I think Amish for the fist
fighting they use their hands they're
out in the fields all day I'm sure that
when they need to settle something they
roll up their sleeves
um and then the middle was spelling bee
spelling they speak different languages
Hebrews very hard but so is German I
think it's a tie yeah yeah all right
unexpected benefits of becoming Amish
you'll be healthier okay you'll be less
stressed you'll develop a strong sense
of community you'll be closer to God
you'll appreciate everything more you'll
learn new skills
seriously Google is there any fat Amish
people Google fat Amish people I don't
think you have many fan Amish but why
they're eating butter and molasses like
the cows yeah but but the amount of work
you don't see fat Amish you don't really
see fat Chinese oh here's a couple of
fatties
wife yeah that's a fat Amish
person yeah you got some okay so we do
have some fat Amish all right yeah that
what this is a gorgeous black makes
sense I can't use weight loss apps but
yeah I can't they're not there they
don't they're not intermittent fasting
all right so we cannot become Amish or
we can become Amish so I can dedicate my
life me a Cuban Italian man from New
York that was raised Catholic can become
ingratiated into the Amish community you
believe that are you saying yes to me as
pimp the person who had a joint earlier
or are you saying yes to me as someone
who's educated as somebody who respects
the Amish I think you could I think they
would be honored to have you lead the
community lead it no I gotta tell you
right now you're not that many steps
away from it with that being you look
like that any uh any trans Amish people
let's see let's look at that and then
this we got to talk about this
basketball in Vegas yeah what about
homeless like are they allowed to be gay
I doubt it so again she's so strict
words I don't think I don't think that
you uh
if Tran okay wise uh Orthodox oh wow
trans Orthodox wow I'm sure that's
interesting human beings were Amish that
left that wanna be trans yeah where are
the trans Amish somebody says if trans
is a natural variation where the trans
Amish how come all the Amish boys how
come all the uh Amish boys you meet our
boy are strong comfortable being boys
how come all the Amish girls you meet
are girlish and strongest girls and
happiness
um
okay
it is interesting but because they have
there are people whose moms and dads are
were once Amish because they left
rumspringer they came out wrong string
and they never went back there is a
point in time where they go away right
there was a whole show about him like
sandals Jamaica yeah they'll go out and
then and then rum Springer and then oh
it's Pennsylvania Dutch
um basically the mom and dad sit there
now and say you're about to be 18. here
is an all-expense paid trip to sandals
Jamaica yeah you're gonna go there for
you know for a week you're gonna eat
whatever you want there talk to whoever
you want there you come back you last
one you let us know after that if it's
your family or sandals that's it that's
it rum Springer and then people okay so
what it is is a rite of passage of
growth in adolescence for some Amish use
during which time they face fewer
restrictions on their behavior and are
not subject to the ordnog German word
for order the specific system of
Unwritten Community Norms that governs
their sect so that means they could go
wild yeah but you can't even date hate a
non-anomish person right but I think
that they can if you're in rumspring I
think it's almost like The Purge you
know in the movie The Purge when you got
24 hours of just anything goes I think
that's what rumspring is it's the Amish
way to purge what's that what's that
vacation where you're going like
everybody could like have sex Hedonism
yeah
yeah normally Rumspringa begins at 16
and ends when a youth chooses either to
be baptized in Amish church or leave
when they choose oh so you don't have to
leave
can you leave and come back can you test
the water I think I've heard of that
that's like a thing yeah you can go back
yeah interesting wow so you if you were
Amish you could actually go go nuts and
then retire and then just when you're
done with it all you're sick of it all
it is interesting how you might find
that even though like we're reading
about this being like how could you live
like that if they don't know any better
or they don't know any different not
better if they don't know any different
if they might be like when you let me
out of it I don't like it the way I feel
I want to go back to this might be a
very easy life because every because
there's no striving for it's just you
know what you have to do the rules are
simple you believe in God you stay good
to your faith you stay Amish you you
take care of the horse you take care of
the farm there's no you don't have to
like what a man you don't have a million
apps you don't have to have credit cards
you don't have to do any of that yeah
what amenities can they indulge in
though like what what's our dealer do
they have air condition no do they
listen to the radio can they listen to
salsa windfall right
um could they that would be funny if we
should go out to eat to a regular
restaurant like I mean are they a free
will but like in in it within their Like
rules they stay healthy the old age and
here's their secret start with
um uh the Amish communities are agrarian
meaning only with the farm they all they
do is farm with no modern farm equipment
meaning all work has to be done by hand
in 2004 the American College of sports
medicine which is the best college
fitted Amish volunteers with pedometers
to determine how much physical activity
they perform the results are dramatic
Amish men took 18 425 steps a day and
women 14 196 steps Amish women got to
get off the Turkish compared with
non-amish people who are encouraged by
doctors to shoot for at least 10 000
steps and typically fail I don't I get
ten thousand steps like five times a
month yeah I almost never get I have to
actually try to get it yeah
um including other forms of manual labor
lifting chopping sewing planting the
Amish are six times as active as a
random sample of people from 12
countries friends
um one result of this is that four
percent of Amish people are obese only
four percent compared with 36.5 of the
overall U.S population Amish children
are about one-third as likely as Amish
to be obese this means 50 lower rates of
type 2 diabetes which the other article
said there is zero diabetes the near
absence of tobacco in the Amish
community some men do smoke cigars
um but it's 63 lower rate of
tobacco-related cancers
um honest people also had rates of all
cancers that were 40 lower than the rest
of the Ohio population oh look look at
the next thing though cardiovascular
disease is one area in which the Amish
do not have an edge with blood pressure
and heart disease rates slightly higher
than those of other populations wow some
of that might be attributable to the
Amish diet which is heavy on pancakes
eggs sausage for breakfast and meat
potatoes gravy and bread for dinner
that'll do it I am working the farm can
burn a lot of that stuff off but it's
not but all the fat salt and carbs will
take it all the most powerful weapon in
the Amish long life Arsenal however may
be genes the Amish population in the US
is 300 is about 300 118 000 descended
from just 200 families that immigrated
in the 1700s that's got to be a lot of
inbreeding though dude that's insane it
did their whole population is from your
family so
a unique people you know 200 families
that's it 200 families live in the
apartment building around the corner
from here exactly that's the whole Amish
lineage that's the lineage wow that's
crazy they mostly marry within their own
communities which means the genes that
existed when their ancestors got to
America have remained that can be a
dangerous thing if bad genes are hidden
in the mix but a good thing if genes are
sound while no communities without
genetic problems the Amish seem to have
gotten a lucky draw now how talks about
any diversity in the Amish community
10 percent longer average lifespan
are there any non-white Amish
yeah can't be well I mean
I mean not one person married someone
other than someone there has to have
been uh something a Chinese an Asian
Amish you can't all just be white people
and if they are why are they not getting
in trouble oh they're Black Amish
are there Hispanic Amish
by definition I guess no but like has
anyone married in and become
right now I don't think turn to oh well
yeah is there Amish outside of America
like in South America things like that
like are there other like is it just in
those states are they only here though
they're only here now Pennsylvania Ohio
so they have the you'll find Amish
communities in Canada Bolivia Argentina
and more Argentina interesting that's
like you got Nazis and the Amish in
Argentina there's a pressure then for
them to keep their
their lot their lifestyle community in
Atlanta live however while the Amish are
governed by the law oh do arms people
have social security numbers they're
governed by the law they don't want to
have social security numbers wow these
people are off the grid however they do
get one when they join the church as an
adult because the Amish come from an
anabaptist tradition they believe that
you should be baptized as an adult when
you're fully able to consent I like that
consent uh just because I I poured I I
baptize my baby she I feel the same way
with Instagram you know I posted a lot
of pictures of my older daughter when
she was younger I'm like
Family Photos is one thing but it's like
now it's like there could be pictures
what if she gets used as a meme and then
she it finds out about it in college and
she's like why did you but now I don't
my younger one I don't we don't post
pictures or if we do it's it's on our
private account like no but I never
thought about that and same thing with
that's good about baptism why not why
don't you get to re-choose your you get
we get a rum Springer for religion when
the kids are 18. you wanna I base you
Catholic but you want to go fundamental
it's Muslim do it you're up it's up to
you I agree actually I really do agree
that's what I'm saying why not I mean
people you know this is fascinating to
me I gotta I honestly we take a trip
let's take a trip and I actually I gotta
go I gotta go see if my kids want to be
Muslim this has been hey babe
don't be a flake don't run away from
your feelings babe don't be afraid don't
be ashamed don't hesitate to say hey
babe hey babe hey babe
[Music]